the Amir of Qatar shik Tam bin hammad
althani is about to speak at the UN
General Assembly let's listen in to his
address in the name God most gracious
most merciful your Excellency the
president of the general assembly your
Excellency the Secretary General of the
United Nations honorable audience may
God's peace mercy and blessings be upon
you at the outset I would like to
congratulate his Excell Mr Dennis
Francis for assuming the presidency of
the 78th session of the general assembly
wishing him success I would like also to
express my appreciation to his
Excellency Mr CH Boshi for his efforts
in presiding over the 77th session I
would like to commend the efforts made
by his Excellency Mr Antonio gues the
Secretary General of the United Nations
as well as the Personnel of the United
Nations towards the Fulfillment of its
lofty
goals allow me at first
to offer my sincere condolences to his
majesty King Muhammad I 6 and to the
Fraternal Moroccan people for the
victims of the devastating earthquake I
would like also to extend my condolences
to Libya to the government and people of
Libya over the victims of the floods
there we pray to God Almighty for the
speedy recovery of the injured and for
the deceased to rest in peace and we
reiterate our full solidarity with them
in this
tragedy Mr President we are fortunate to
be living in an era of
unprecedented accelerating progress
where Innovation prevails in all walks
of life especially medicine technology
and science and where humanity is more
capable than ever to harness resources
for a decent life for all
Humanity
the consecutive
Innovations have led to productivity
prosperity and a level of communication
amongst people that can be tantamount to
science
fiction this
development has enabled us to achieve a
lot of our wishes however this came with
a coast for the people and the planet
the average life expectancy and the
standard of living of the majority of
humanity have risen however this is
coupled with an increase in the rates of
poverty and unemployment not to mention
that there is growing awareness of the
lack of injust the lack of Justice in
wealth distribution and the dire
consequences on environment and in terms
of genetics and artificial intelligence
we have a lot of potential that could uh
achieve prosperity for the whole
Humanity however the gap between the
possibilities and reality is
widening so in this era and as poten
those potentials unfold we find peoples
grappling with child labor Hunger
unemployment Civil
Wars meanwhile the developed countries
guard their borders against the influx
of refugees as if the peoples on this
earth live in two different
eras the
accelerating de technical development
and the growing Reliance thereon open up
unprecedented prospects for Humanity to
develop for the better and undoubtedly
Science and Technology are crucial for
increasing productivity and improving a
human life quality however embracing the
means without responsibly thinking of
the ends to which those means are used
have led to Major disasters such as
using nuclear weapons conducting
dangerous experiments and humans as well
as genocide in concentration
camps it is incumbent on us to keep Pace
with the scientific and Technical
development and to encourage the same in
our countries meanwhile barriers between
countries in this field must be removed
however at the same
time we should not ignore risks such as
deep fakes violation of privacy hacking
fishing identity theft educational
process disruption by facilitating
plagiarism as well as human deception
ples therefore and in addition to the
necessity of cooperation and investment
in developing those Technologies we
reiterate our call
for Unison to prevent the misuse of
cyber space and to regulate this vital
aspect on the basis of the rules of the
international
law in this context the web Summit
2024 is set to take place in Doha this
will be a very important opportunity to
review development in the field of
technology and to create new cooperation
opportunities in the realm of technology
for the benefit of humanity as a whole
and I would like to take this occasion
to welcome you all in
Doha Mr President we must not forget
that there are peoples around the world
especially in our region that are
overwhelmed by the present tragedies
thus the issues that I have just
mentioned might
seem to them as luxury thus if we
truthfully call ourselves International
Community and not merely entities
separate entities we have to work and to
strive towards ending Injustice
afflicting those people at least in
accordance with the resolutions of this
body and the international
law it is unacceptable for the
Palestinian people to continue to
languish under the Yoke and the
intransigence of the Israeli occupation
and the rejection
by consecutive Israeli governments of
any just political solution according to
International legitimacy it is
conspicuous to all that the inaction by
the international organization to take
procedures against the occupation has
given Israel the opportunity and it
continues to give Israel the
opportunities
to undermine the pillars of the
two-state solution to the extent that
the occupation has become tantamount to
an upper to a Brazen and conspicuous
upper TI system in the 21
Century this has been very conspicuous
to
the to the extent that even some of
Israel's friends have noticed
that Israel also responds to Arab peace
and normalization initiatives with more
Nationalist and Ultra Orthodox inion and
extremism that is reflected in
government coalitions and further
settlement expansion in addition to the
judaization of Jerusalem attacks on the
holy sites and using heavy-handed and
draconian measures against the people in
Gaza qat provides and extends political
humanitarian and development support to
our brotherly people in Palestine and we
also contribute towards rebuilding the
Gaza strep which is reeling Under The
Siege in addition and in and the Embargo
in addition to its continuous
contribution to the Ona
funds we
also maintain our Firm Stance regarding
the fairness of this
cause
as for Syria it is
unacceptable to condone the
Injustice sustained by the Fraternal
people of Syria as Destiny the
crisis is awaiting a comprehensive
settlement through a political process
leading to a political transition in
accordance with the Geneva declaration 1
and the security Council resolution 22
54 while maintaining sy's Integrity
sovereignty and Independence it's
regrettable to witness this year the
outbreak of violence in the sedan which
had dire effect and impact on the
Sudanese people and which has
exacerbated the crisis of refugees we
condemn all crimes perpetrated against
civilians in the capital Kum and in
darur and we call for holding the
perpetrators thereof accountable also we
call for putting an end to the violence
and to resort to reason to spare
civilians the consequences of fighting
and we do stress our support to all
regional and international efforts to
facilitate ceasefire and dialogue
between all political powers in the
sedan for the future of the sedan and in
fraternal
Lebanon
where the Spectre of danger hangs over
the state's
institutions we do stress the need for
finding a sustainable solution to the
political vacuum introducing mechanisms
that thwart its recurrence and forming a
government capable of addressing the
aspirations of the Lebanese people it is
regrettable for the suffering of this
fraternal people to be prolonged just
because of political and personal
calculations and in we call for settling
the crisis according to the National
dialogue the gulf initiative and the
relevant Security Council resolutions
and when it comes to Libya we do stress
our unwavering support for the Endeavors
of the special representative of the
Secretary General and the head of the
United Nations support mission in Libya
we do support his efforts to achieve
tangible results to resolve the Libyan
crisis it is clear that solution in all
fraternal countries that I have
mentioned lies in consensus consensus on
the rule of law state and citizenship
regarding the situation in Afghanistan
we continue to coordinate International
efforts and facilitating dialogue with
the United Nations and the countries
concerned in addition to the caretaker
government of a Afghanistan to ensure
compliance to the Doha
agreement to avoid the recurrence of
past mistakes and to prevent
Afghanistan from spiraling into a
difficult to manage humanitarian crisis
or becoming a safe haven for terrorist
individuals and groups we also have to
work to ensure that the Afghan people
receive the needed international support
and assistance and enjoy human rights
particularly minority rights and women's
rights to education and work when we
speak about our region we would like to
reiterate our appreciation of the
detante and the Breakthrough that we
have witnessed this year which is
represented in the constructive dialogue
and the reestablishment of ties between
the sisterly countries the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia and the Islamic Republic of
Iran as well as between the Arab
Republic of Egypt and the Republic of
Turkey Mr
President the war in Europe drags on and
along with Russia and Ukraine it is
consuming Europe in its entirety and it
is affecting the whole world in vital
areas such as energy and food and in
absence in the absence of a prospect for
a permanent political
solution and taking into
account
the ability of certain countries to
continue this
war
incessantly the only thing and the only
aspiration that people are looking up to
is a
Truce based
on the damage sustained by the peoples
of both countries and the peoples of the
world and and because the status quo
cannot be accepted we reiterate our call
on all parties to comply with the United
Nations chter and the international law
and to respect the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of
States we also call upon them to resort
to radical peaceful
Solutions based on those
principles Mr
President
our
region is blessed with tremendous
potentials and opportunities and our
peoples are tolerant Humane peaceloving
and
talented during the 2022 World Cup
inq there was an opportunity for
interaction between peoples and it was
an opportunity for the world to see our
people as they are and to learn about
our our culture and values and to learn
about Qatar and qatar's status as a
global destination and Nexus between
east and west and we emphasize the role
that Sports could play in Building
Bridges of communication and RMA between
peoples and cultures I hope we had
contributed through this tournament to
Breaking the stereotypes and presenting
a new exciting and safe tournament
formula to the
world in qar we had a dream we had a
dream for our country to be one of the
prosperous Nations whose people enjoy
well-being and prosperity we have
invested for decades in uh to achieve
our Dream by Planning and Development
work we have achieved a lot thanks to
God and the solidarity of everyone in
Qatar while investing in liquefied gas
was a leverage to realize that dream
this investment also enabled us to play
an important role in addressing the
energy challenge around the world by
embrac ering a realistic Vision that
takes into consideration the world needs
for a diverse mix of different energy
sources and by using the highest levels
of advanced
technology which is environment friendly
we do realize that energy export imposes
obligations on us as a reliable
partner with world countries at the same
time it makes it incumbent on us to be
respons before our people and our future
Generations thus qat continues to
develop its Sovereign fund and diversify
the sources of its income including
investment in clean energy the state of
Qatar pursues environmentally friendly
policies and supports various projects
to
protect to protect the same in this
regard we are uh going to host theq
Horticultural Expo next
month
the state of qar responsibly Works
towards strengthening its role in
providing humanitarian Aid and mediation
efforts and to resolve conflicts that
affect the world the path to resolve
conflicts through peaceful means is a
long and strenuous path but it is less
coly than Wars and our commitment to
continue our efforts in facilitating and
making peace is a firm commitment deeply
rooted in the core of our foreign policy
Mr President we stress
that we take pride in our partnership
with this international
organization and this is evidenced by o
by qatar's opening the United Nations
house in last March which includes 12 un
offices so far H last March or in March
of this year my country hosted the fifth
United Nations conference on the least
developed
countries which is considered one of the
most prominent International
fora during this
forum efforts were galvanized to achieve
the ambitious goals of the Doha action
program for the benefit of the least
developed countries for during the
decade of 2020 to 2031 we do reiterate
that the state of qat is a major and
active part in the Endeavors made to
respond to the priorities and needs of
these countries thus we welcome the
sustainable development goals Summit
held
yesterday we are also pleased to
announce that the state of Qatar is once
again undertaking a leading role in
major debates Under the Umbrella of the
United
Nations most recent of which is our
collaboration with Ireland to facilitate
government negotiations on the political
declaration adopted by the sustainable
development goal Summit yesterday we
believe that cooperation in those areas
contributes to hedge against the waves
of refugees which have become a real
problem for Europe as well as for
neighboring African and Asian countries
allow me at this point to stress the
importance of combating racism and the
campaigns of enticement against entire
people's religions and civilizations and
in this occasion on this occasion I
would like to tell my Muslim Brethren
that we should not
fall prey to any idiot or mentally sick
person who cursed provoke Us by burning
the Quran and the Quran says God
Almighty says in the Quran Embrace
forgiveness and enjoy what is right and
turn away from the ignorant at the same
time I would like to tell all those who
justify those ugly and hideous acts uh
as freedom of expression I would like to
tell them that comprising the sanctity
of others deliber deliberately should
not be seen as an example of the freedom
of expression in
conclusion it is incumbent on all
leaders to empower their peoples and to
enable their
peoples to live in peace and security
and to look forward to a better future
for their posterity their are obstacles
at the level of the International
Community mainly represented in the
failure to subject contradictions and
competition between major countries
on on certain issues to the minimum
binding principles owing to the
variations in governance systems these
issues which concern all of humanity
include climate change environmental
matters in general poverty and the
blatant Injustice represented by
occupation racism and war crimes this is
the consensus or the unanimity that
should take place in this international
organization in order not to be
overwhelmed by details and to safeguard
the future of entire peoples from loss
due to the unwillingness of those
countries to cooperate in implementing
international law and peace be upon
you on behalf of the assembly I wish to